joining us here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is a man i mean his the
manning cast as you know i have said
nothing
but uh uh love for because it is just a
total delight and the eli manning show
can be seen on the giants youtube
channel the next episode drops
uh two days before
new year's
with bill murray as his guest oh wow eli
manning back here on the rich eisen show
how you doing eli
i'm doing great rich how are you i'm
doing better i'm doing better for
talking to you so um
why was kurt warner wearing your jacket
last night eli was that something from
back in the mid-aughts that he got from
you that jacket from last night did you
see that
i didn't see that you didn't wear my
jacket oh my gosh what happened oh eli
you've been off of twitter yeah
yeah i've been off twitter today okay uh
kurt yeah kurt wore jacket last night um
it was this big silver puffy jacket
um and he's been he got roasted uh big
time roasted for it uh lance briggs said
it looked like a wrapped up uh burrito
um
uh nfl network said it looked like a
hershey's kiss like that sort of thing i
thought you'd definitely see i follow
you on twitter so if i check my twitter
did you comment on it um have i
commented on it i have not yet no okay
i'm sorry i let you down
is that how my tweet made the manning
cast a few weeks ago where you noticed
it during a commercial break is that
what happened exactly i noticed that i
noticed everything you do but i
appreciate it
[Laughter]
hey eli uh this the manning cast has
been an absolute delight uh i'm
wondering if this is what you guys
envisioned when you decided to do this
for espn yeah i think so i think so this
is what we were you know what we hope
would people would find entertaining and
so i think just the idea of
of peyton and i um
you know just you know hanging out talk
talking ball uh taking shots at each
other and you know having some fun
guests on to uh you know um
you know guys you know a little bit
where you can you can poke fun at them
you know once they get sensitive no
one's gonna get their feelings hurt and
so
you know we didn't we kind of knew going
in
you know the first couple was gonna be a
little bit of hey let's see what works
what doesn't work and and see what you
know fans like and adjust
from that we tried to have a few like
kind of scripted things early on with
some plays peyton's like trying on
helmets he was a little nervous
uh i think a little excited he was a
little excited the first couple episodes
that we kind of uh you know got through
those uh those and and said hey we don't
we don't have to plan much that's what
the game's for you know have some guests
playing for the guest but when we're
just talking ball just let's just let's
talk you know something's gonna happen
that we can discuss and find interesting
just from our knowledge of being around
the game for so long and then again so
both of you are those studios built in
your uh nearby or in your basements are
those really i'm in my basement yeah i'm
i'm in my basement and um
you know and so yeah i i when i uh when
i built it it wasn't planned to be a
studio to host monday night football
that was not i was not in the in the
game plan but uh peyton somehow
convinced the buddy of his to let him
use his um kind of garage little area
and so i'm sure you know at first you
know it's kind of you know it was kind
of sold as hey it's just like a zoom
it's easy you pop right in it's not
quite
a little more lights more cameras more
tvs more people in your area than maybe
we we uh were initially told so your
commute is just downstairs he's got to
hop in a car that's what you're saying
to get to work you've got to hop in a
car maybe not a bad thing maybe not a
bad thing i just go right downstairs uh
my kids love they love monday nights so
they kind of like the excitement the
people around there's we go they usually
come down uh kind of in the basement
with me around you know around seven
o'clock i go down and just kind of go
over my notes and get it make sure
everything's working and they they run
down and just start you know they like
all the cameras they get the you know
the point laser pointer they're on the
little tablet they're drawing things
they're yeah they like all the toys and
start dancing and when you know you know
they see a camera they kind of you know
that's there they they light up
and start acting out which uh which
makes it fun so i mean and the thing
that i enjoy seeing too well it's just
you know you guys and your just your
natural habitat of being brothers you
know and um and also just you know
behind the scenes in a well i never
thought i'd see peyton in skinny jeans
to be honest with you um also i've never
seen him inhale his hand before how come
you're not caught on camera eating do
you not what why wha what what's up with
that eli well because i'm i'm east coast
time so it you know the game starts at 8
15. i've already eaten
he's in denver you know game starts at 6
15. he's got the commute before so he's
not hungry at 5 30. he's got a
you know so that's at halftime is his
dinner
so it's it's an unfortunate scheduling
uh i guess wouldn't call it a snafu an
issue
um and so
um and i just noticed there was one week
where he
he
left and he turned his back to eat so
and they zoomed in
well because he was doing it the first
couple weeks as well he'd just be eating
there devouring food and i
i kind of just
secretly said to the producer i'm like
hey are we filming this let's just make
sure like we're catching this for future
reference and we need to we need to go
back and so
and then another week again he was you
know when he was just
eating a full chicken
you know just like it was
i don't know fried chicken but it wasn't
just with his hands and some like you
know hey just double checking we're
recording this
not not thinking i was going to use it
at the time but he took a shot at me for
something and i just
i kind of you know brought it up and you
know credit to the producers they
quickly can reference anything that's on
that has been filmed uh
previously so they went right to it and
and there you go so a lot of it is you
know it's not planned it's not scripted
and you know so that's that's the idea
you know i think peyton and i both
understand it like
hey you know
the us making fun of each other is what
what people like what people enjoy and
so you almost you know try to create it
like i'm you know trying to
throw softballs to each other so they
can you know just you know bash you know
he can bash me and vice versa well the
thing i also like too is just uh both of
yours although you either hide it more
or what have your distaste for
bad football just
you know clock management oh gosh
peyton's biggest pet peeve i think i've
i've discovered yeah clock management
before halftime right and uh or into the
game is just you know
but frustrates him more than anything
else absolutely i i see all that but i i
enjoy that and of course you're both of
your brilliant knowledge of pre-snap
post-snap then diagnosing it um it it is
it's great and when the games are tight
in the fourth quarter i just love
locking in with you and if you have a
guest that also like russell wilson week
one terrific i mean right you know it's
just great just locking in
with you guys about what's to be
expected what happened what should have
happened it's great elon truly
congratulations on that thank you no
thank you i think it's uh it's been a
lot of fun you know when i when i
retired from football and trying to
figure out
kind of what i wanted to do uh going
forward i didn't you know at the time i
didn't realize there was a job where you
could just watch football and make fun
of your brother
[Laughter]
i'm glad that was an option i think it
just you know it's the perfect job for
me so i'm glad that that's available eli
manning here on the rich eisen show and
the eli manning show so you got
you hung out with bill murray and this
is going to drop in advance of bears
giants next thursday a week from this
thursday
exactly how was that you know how was
that it was it was unbelievable and it
wasn't originally it wasn't meant to be
a full show it's just gonna be kind of a
little tidbit but we had so much good
information i am a huge bill murray fan
just growing growing up you know with
especially two older brothers with
peyton cooper they're five and seven
years older so like you know i was
probably you know watching stripes uh
and meatballs before i before i should
have you know from ghostbusters to
caddyshack
you know anything you know groundhog day
like i know i know every line i know
that his name and all those chara i've
seen all those movies so many times
where you know it was just fun for me to
sit there kind of just talk talk old
school movies
what he was improving what was really
scripted
um and just to hang out with him and
then and then you know we kind of just
were walking around how he and all of a
sudden he just
reacts to the
people that we were around i don't want
to give away too much what happened to
the show but it involves some foreign uh
exchange students i believe who had no
idea who i was but immediately
recognized bill murray and what what
proceeds to happen it's just you know
such you know raw uh footage of him just
in action and he's just it was an
awesome day for me one of my childhood
heroes that's great um you know and so
it's it's been a lot of fun i guess you
know normally through the show with sean
o'hara he wasn't there this day but
normally with sean who's you know
i know you y'all know well yeah you know
it's good to see but one of my best
friends and former teammates so kind of
the same you know similar relationship
as peyton and i where we can attack each
other there there's no no sensitivity we
have a sensitivity fine rule
uh if you're a little sensitive you get
it upset about anything it's a fine that
you have to pay it eventually goes to
charity well i mean you all said kevin
durant rich climate who's been on this
show as well that that that episode was
earlier this month um kevin hart i mean
this is fun uh
but you know bill murray is like
famously difficult to book like you have
to call like a number and he answers it
from a pay phone or something crazy
right so how did you get them how did
how did you land building i i
just you know i have my sources
that was kind of part of the deal okay
it's like fight club it's like fight
club you can't talk about it okay first
rule about booking bill murray you can't
tell anybody how you booked bill murray
okay yeah it's that that ain't easy man
and letterman the other night too i mean
you guys have been jon stewart i mean
you guys have had incredible guests and
you're getting the same here for eli
manning for the eli manning show and
again um you're getting a sponsor next
year you got duncan joining you next
year does that mean uh we get uh uh free
munchkins or something like that eli
just forever having you on the program
to promote it we get that for since
you're promoting my show i'll send you
some munchkins thank you sir i
appreciate that and again we just want
to make sure we know we're talking about
donuts here um oh okay yes that's
exactly what we're talking about so uh
eli let me just ask you this question
the best team you've seen on monday
night football right now from your
perspective
is who um
i mean i mean uh
you know how the nfl changes every week
obviously i thought the patriots were
playing really good football and for
them to win a game where their
quarterback throws three passes in in
the game is was pretty impressive but
then they go out
and get you know get spanked by
indianapolis it's kind of their you know
following week i don't know if they got
spanked we got got beat by indy so
um
you know i think i still think they're a
really good team their defense plays
plays well um and then you catch you
know you catch some teams
you know early on that that weren't
playing as well and you look at like
kansas city that wasn't playing well and
now they're playing they're playing
great offenses clicking defense is
clicking so it definitely changes over
the course of the season but you know
you kind of feel like you know
you know kansas city is has regained
their
uh mojo and it's kind of the team to
beat right now okay so you like kansas
city what about in the nfc i mean you
see rogers playing out of his skull uh
yeah brady ran into another saints wall
um that was you know that's crazy
in the regular season obviously so what
do you think in the nfc what's your
breakfast yeah i think like you said i
think the the packers are playing uh are
playing the best football kind of all
around um
rogers i think just kind of faking this
you know toe injury just the people you
know think he's hurt and he's just you
know throwing four touchdowns every game
and looks fine to me out there um
and yeah i mean i think i still think
tampa's
right up there with them just um you
know that you know you're always going
to have that tough game they lost you
know they lost a couple of guys but
they're still still still talented and
uh you know have a little time to get
back healthy and and make the playoffs
and
and uh we'll still be good going down
that stretch i believe and then i i'll
ask you the question i know all my
giants friends would love for me to ask
you uh daniel jones who i know uh you
have a fondness for um and and his
uh season there's just i don't know how
you evaluate right the offensive
coordinator gets fired in the middle
he's now hurt he's not going to play the
rest of the year and they have
the organization needs to make an
evaluation
on him i would say toots sweet certainly
with maybe a new gm and who the heck
knows what's going on there what would
your
opinion be on what the giants should do
in regards to your successor at the
position yeah you know obviously it's a
tough situation with everything going on
with you know uh
with the offense and the struggles
they've had
all season and so i think it's really
that's kind of a call for for joe judge
and john mara and
um you know ghetto men and what they're
gonna do uh
from all all those things and and
daniel jones is in the mix there as well
and so you know i think it's hard to get
a true evaluation you know i think he's
made some you know some adjustments and
fixed some of the turnover problems but
you know overall just did not you know
score enough offensively and you know i
think it's not it's not just the
quarterback problem it's from receiver
injuries to running back injuries
you know just a problem kind of across
the board and make it make it tough to
get a true
analysis of of what you have and so i
think they gotta you know dive deep and
really look at
what what the other options are uh as
well and do you you know give them
another year to try to uh have a have a
feel or do you you know make a trade and
get an established guy or go to the
draft obviously so i mean it's it's not
not none of these are
are easy decisions to make um you know i
don't think i i don't there's not an
easy answer there's not a right answer
right necessarily it's just trying to
trying to make the best and and
and
and make some of those tough decisions
that's why you know hey you are the
owner or you are the gm and head coach
because you're you're you know qualified
to make those tough decisions
eli really appreciate your your time i'm
uh always enjoy when you come on here
and uh i'm really loving the manning
cast with you and your brother and i
know sometimes next one is is this
monday are you doing this monday dolphin
saints is that what you're doing no we
got we got we're doing the following
once we got uh uh steelers and brown oh
gosh that's going to be yeah then we've
got a playoff one we're doing the monday
night playoff game that's gonna be
exciting that will be exciting for that
for sure and uh look i know if you're
ever needing time of tap dancing uh i'm
there you know uh at home if you need me
to come on and sing some karaoke you
know uh and peyton certainly knows since
i've awakened him many times at the pro
bowl um you know one in the morning you
know i can fill some time if necessary
i'm there for you always always i've got
your back
if we have you on you have to sing
karaoke what are you gonna say that's
life certainly since if you're tap
dancing i think it works you know what i
mean like that's nice sometimes things
don't work out they don't bounce your
way but you know shot down in april you
know uh
come back in may that's it you know what
i mean there it is that's it i hear you
you know that i'm clear i'm there for
you eli have a great holiday with you
and your family and my best to your
whole
best your folks please send my best oh
by the way i got i got lane kiffin
coming up uh next hour you got any
message from for him at all uh
go go go win in the sugar bowl let's go
okay go to new orleans go to my hometown
there you go oh hey
stay away from the hurricane okay and by
the way and i'm sure he would admit it
okay so i will do that and i'm sure he'd
want me to write right back at you and
say hello to your your nephew for him i
think that's probably what he would like
as well
right exactly
ole miss playing great football
fun fun to be an ole miss fan uh this
year okay take care of yourself elon
you're the best thank you right back at
you eli manning show host
and check out the latest episode on the
giants youtube page december 30th
with bill murray that is gonna be a fun
watch hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here